people with outstanding bench warrants  in north las vegas had the chance at a  clean slate today  the municipal court hosted a special  event at the north las vegas justice  center to help people get those warrants  quashed  organizers say having a warrant can take  a huge toll on people's lives  this goes from having a driver's license  suspended to the risk of being arrested  on a warrant  financial toll if especially if you're  working and you have to take that time  off work  so what we want to do is we want to  catch that before our folks we  know we're met with those types of  obstacles and get them  to a place where they can get that  warrant quashed  and move forward with their lives  attorneys volunteered their time to help  attendees  organizers say even though some cases  are taken out of warrant  status this does not necessarily mean  the case is going to close